hey this is pressure Locker consider the
points 1 1 & 2 2 they can be connected
by the straight line y equals x
similarly consider the points 1 1 & 2 7
they can be connected by the parabola y
equals 2x squared minus 1 these are
examples of connecting points with the
polynomial that has integer coefficients
now consider the points 1 3 & 3 2 can
you connect these points by a polynomial
that has integer coefficients that is
can you find an equation of the
following form that passes through the
two points where all of the coefficients
are integers meaning they are positive
or negative whole numbers if you can
find an equation that passes through
these two points if you cannot prove why
it's impossible to do so can you figure
it out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution
so it would seem you should be able to
find a polynomial that passes through
with these two points because you're not
restricted to the degree of the
polynomial however that turns out to be
not the case it is actually impossible
to find a polynomial with integer
coefficients that passes through these
two points we can in fact prove this by
contradiction so let's suppose we have a
solution because this solution passes
through the point 1 comma 3 that means
we can substitute y equals 3 and x
equals 1 since 1 raised to any power is
equal to 1 this simplifies to be 3 is
equal to the sum of the coefficients and
we know that each coefficient is an
integer so what we proven is that the
sum of these integer coefficients is 3
which is an odd number we also know this
solution would have to pass through the
point 3 comma 2 so we can substitute y
equals 2 and x equals 3 now we have to
simplify this a little bit consider the
powers of 3 since 3 is an odd number and
an odd number times an odd number is
equal to another odd number we can
conclude that all powers of 3 are odd
numbers so that means 3 to the power of
K is always an odd number furthermore if
the coefficient in a particular power is
even then that coefficient times 3 to
the power of K will be an even number
this is because an even number times any
number will be an even number if on the
other hand the coefficient is odd then
the coefficient multiplied by 3 to some
power will also be an odd number because
an odd number times another odd number
is an odd number
so we can conclude that two has the same
evenness or oddness as the sum of the
coefficients we can write this in
another form we can say that 2 is
congruent to the sum of the coefficients
when considering modulo 2 and this
implies that the sum of the coefficients
would have to be an even number so on
the one hand we have the sum of the
coefficients being an even number and on
the other hand we have the sum of the
coefficients being an odd number this is
impossible this is a contradiction to
say that some of the coefficients are
both even and odd at the same time
therefore our assumption that we did
find a solution is not correct and thus
there is no such polynomial that can
pass through these two points with
integer coefficients did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch around my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure Locker and if you like
this video please check out my books
there are links in the video description